my name is androgyne in the world I am from Kyiv I work as a radio host and screenwriter and for the first time I went to the Maidan on November 21, 2013 the very first day it seemed that this was the most important thing that was happening in my life and that I should be here and everything else that I did before as if it began to lose its meaning, it seems to me that the Maidan showed Ukrainians as people with their own history. I’m in Ukraine, it seems, only 24 years old, a young country, but nevertheless, the culture here has much deeper roots and the fact that these very European values ​​are being pursued here he talks about these guys I am very nostalgic for the Maidan I miss this moment I really want to return to the time when we stood shoulder to shoulder with each other many of us who share made friends there are still friends we found real and like-minded people discovered amazing I definitely discovered a lot of people and remembering this with such sadness that it cannot be returned, it was a moment of good and evil struggle
and life and
death but a very honest moment this
honesty is real happiness and discover